what would you guys like a rap about
disco yeah it's kind of weird just to
say disco I feel like every time people
say this just spell it out just
d.i.s.c.o was that not a big hit over
here okay that's fine disco it was a
huge hit in the UK disco I like that
suggestion did this side of the middle
what you want to rap about
Constantinople wonderful wonderful
Constantinople disco lovely little wedge
over here what you wanna rap over Elton
John nice Elton John
disco Constantinople this side of the
middle what you wanna rap about you said
aliens and you said well one sec what
farm equipment okay I'm gonna say farm
equipment is slightly weirder than
aliens so we'll take that one farm
equipment Elton John disco and what was
yours again concept mobile and let's get
one final one this one come from
anywhere just make sure it's good what
we want some of it brick what rap
legends and you said gremlins
okay we'll combine that for rap gremlins
I like that okay so rap gremlins Elton
John Constantinople farm equipment and
again
disco this then and for your delectation
for your enjoyment for your final thing
you're gonna see this evening is a
little thing called a freestyle rap that
is a rap made up on the spot based
entirely on those suggestions and let's
drop that B and let's get this going rap
gremlins Elton John can't stand to no
pool disco and farm equipment okay why
should we start with let's start simply
with the one we got first I like that
it's gonna be cool you seem very
unconvinced
cards on the floor watching for let me
gyrate dancefloor disco ball turn around
in the seventies plenty of clubs people
in white flares getting up started
rubbing on the person beside them when
they're dancing
they take the bell bottoms of the disco
pants in turn them into skinny jeans out
from Flair's I'll be on the dance floor
kind shapes or the stairs and me like um
maybe John Travolta when it comes to
dance moves I never fall up I made the
moves look so damn easier and to the
right down year Night Fever I want to
say you've got my sunglasses on looking
extravagant like I'm Elton John oh I had
a plan though be real key and play the
piano
look at this gether hits he deserves
this married to kids with the David
Furnish vast furnishings very lush in
his home if I was famous I would get him
on the phone right now I ring him here I
get the bell on say come over here yeah
your name's Elton got a film coming now
it didn't go to plan because it kind of
was critically panned it was rocking man
but that's okay he was the exact
producer he was like yeah my leper will
reducer all the candy green things we
could discuss yeah they had a problem it
was censored in Russia he be shooting
for poo in recently on Instagram had a
post that was sent to me and he was like
Putin you're a hypocrite I've got a farm
equipment some rusty old [ __ ] in the
field
it's a trapdoor Taron Egerton was though
and Jon's act or but the trapdoor by the
trapdoor in the cellar and getting all
the flower man agricultural feller you
can see me combine like a harvester in
the field taking grapes I'm a star out
there I turn it there yellow water to
wine when it comes to harvest at harvest
time I like to get that corn like I'm in
the Midwest or all of this country yeah
I bring every time people get the props
if you feeling scared then you need to
call the cops if you see a gang called
wu-tang but they got a bit of water in
their hand never let the combine like a
big farm engine after midnight the
wu-tang gremlins put it on
it's rambling light Mogwai that's the
one the original grimm got the little
green thing like a Grinch I intend to
talk about jay-z if he was from afar
Chinese land with nothing on
that's a gremlin reference I'm not
saying his race is different to how it
seems when you look with your face that
would be kind of weird and strange what
was the last one we didn't our I got it
in my brain okay I'm gonna say I'm no
fool is it constantinople istanbul
nobody knows and in the 1400 you
wouldn't believe I've got a factor must
leave the Constantinople siege that was
warm ROI all down or the people pillage
in that town who Roman Emperor said his
start to collapse that we need to try
and take Constantine no pullback but
they couldn't they had no hope they
tripped our like double touch with a
skipping rope and there we go finish
with the wrap wait flirty Constantinople
let me go off to Turkey
[Applause]